hi I'm Dorian Bureau and I'm Ricardo
Algeria and we're going to present you
the whooping client library for pipe
okay hi everyone I think we can try to
get started in the meantime a lot of
people maybe are coming it's very early
in the morning I hope you got a good
coffee I think it's worth it it's a it's
it's a really nice project that we have
been doing and it's gonna be it's an
open source project that we have been
done with durian here and basically what
happened was that inside the company we
were using Python for several reason and
most of us were reimplemented in the
same stuff over and over again there was
some logic like data serialization
deserialization that was coming all over
the place right and we said well this
should not happen we should try to
factorize this functionality and so he's
out everything started I started doing
this I started creating data
serialization was creating from from
Python input form and then we started
adding more and more functionalities to
the project couple of words about me I
am Ricardo this is Dori and I'm from
inner is from France and we have been
working with the company for several
years now
and we are the only two contributors of
the project right now it's like 100
percent of the lights is written by us
probably this is gonna change in the
future I hope is gonna change in the
future
which is why we're we're going
open-source so let's see what we're
talking about this is an open source
library to manipulate and evaluate or
firm language expression we are
providing a very simple entry point
there is a single function for this
functionality to do data serialization
and another functions to do this
serialization and this is what I will be
mostly talking about an Andorian
implemented D and we'll explain to you
how to work with local and cloud kernels
are you can start them spawn them
directly from within Python
if you go down the the library is live
from today and this is the URL you can
you can access it and there is also
documentation link that you can go a PP
start should be already working right it
is so okay
so for the first part of the dollar we
will see how you can create from Python
expressions so there is a nice syntax
that we come up with that is used to
generate Python expression from within
pattern to represent symbolic Python
expression sorry Wolfram language
expression we see how this was used
internally for external evaluate and the
benefits that we gained by starting
using it thank you
we will show how the libraries already
taking care for you a lot of common data
types that everyone is using so all
built-in data types of Python including
all structures then we will see how to
serialize custom classes that you have
and that support basically for
serialization when you're using this
library are you can easily switch from
serializing the input form to wxf which
is a format we are going to explain in a
bit and now to deserialize
word form language expressions
so I don't know if you're familiar with
this because this is a new functionality
in I think was eleven point two there
Corp I don't sell they're really nice
and basically it shows that notebooks
can really be used for you know any kind
of language not only work from the
language this is the direction that we
are at time to take it now and as you
see the it just look like a court cell
except that when you when you run it it
will use external evaluator to run the
code that that is it there are several
kinds of cells that you can use this is
the white one
and and let's see what this what this
code is doing so the entry point that I
was speaking about is Minister prose
okay we say from more from client
language import WL so what is w LW n if
you're curious you can check out the
source code is it's really one of the
nicest field of Python it's there is a
dynamic language that allows you to do
very nice thing and what is happening is
that every time you access with a with
an attribute the dot syntax it creates a
symbol for you and this is a symbol that
that is represented by a class in Python
that is called war from language symbol
and each time you call it with
parenthesis it creates for your warfarin
language function so with those two
construct we can represent almost any
expression in the world from language
and so each time you do Wolfram language
dot PI for example it creates for you
the symbol pi that that and let's see
what what this is doing so when you when
we do export this is now returning a
byte array in in the cells but first
let's see what is doing in a terminal
okay
so the this function returns Python 3
bytes or Python to string and so the the
serialize are always return binary data
and you see that when you are doing when
you are taking all those Python objects
they're serialize in the input form that
is suitable to be used in warfare memory
so you can just copy paste this code
into a notebook and you will get out
this code and try to do that but it's
very easy we can just take this guy and
put it somewhere in a notebook and
evaluate it and the same thing happens
here in a pile on cell if you just
evaluate it so we are using the very
same technology for python cells so
every time you write Python code the
output of the Python code needs to be
imported back in the journal this is
pollen code this is purely button code
it doesn't it doesn't it's just it's
just a symbol
so you're just creating an arbitrary
symbol that is called map does nothing
in python but only when you take that
symbol and you put it into the kernel
the colonel knows what map is got a
meaning there is an evaluator and then
it evaluates so this thing first is
coming out like the representation I
showed you up you need to imagine that
when when I'm executing this this self
from Python this is coming out like
that guy then that guy evaluates and
this is why you get back folds yeah
something like that yeah sure sure it's
it's way easier probably by just seeing
that in the terminal so where is it here
emollient idol okay and I can do pipe
it's a bit confusing because also we we
define a weight I mean w-well that pie
is actually class as you can see and we
make sure that when you when you print
it in a terminal for example it displays
nicely so that's why you don't see the
value well symbol something big we just
put the name of the symbol so the line
when it's written P only this is this is
just our way to print it yeah so this is
just a Python class that it's a really
easy one it got one an tribute that is
called name and is the symbol name when
you are creating a function and let's
say that I have something like yeah got
a same up and you have been close and to
do what I was doing right
now this guy if we do type again this is
a Wolfram language function it's a
Python class that represents function
application it does to construct we can
represent almost any expression in
multimedia and Orion will show you how
to execute the code but this is just so
that the way it works is that in this
library we we have this fundamental
constructor that allows you to generate
an expression then you decide what to do
with them okay so in this case first you
create the expression so you have a big
chunk of code that is creating your word
from a language expression and then you
decide what to do so you can call the
entry point of export and that is
producing you can save it to a file you
can save it as a string whatever or you
take the same very same expression you
do evaluate and that will automatically
start the kernel send the expression
there as for the result deserialized
back through and so all this logic this
boilerplate code it's all implemented by
the library and where is in the very
same code in external evaluate and in
parent search to do that
so the Biden cell takes the takes the
string of the vitam code a it's sent
basically is doing able in pattern there
is a function to evaluate Python code
just evaluated then the result is
exported and evaluate
not all of them no you can see the what
is happening in the barman side in any
case there is no way to lock those those
intermediate steps
and so yeah to get you even more
confused if I do this I'm creating now a
bar chart expression so from a pythons
alive like this big computation that is
producing data and then I want to see
this data and I can just use Wolfram
language for it so I can just create a
bar chart take this area measure lies
that directly or I could have done that
manually by just doing this and then you
know copy paste this guy and do a bar
chart and with this syntax you can also
refer to arbitrary internal context by
using this dot syntax so you keep adding
a dot and it's like the Wolfram language
backtick so that you can refer to
internal context this really helps
keeping the code clean when you're
mixing Python and word from language
code I've been doing it for for for for
internals and I might say that it really
keeps Google readable because with the
syntax you know when you are generating
Wolfram language expression when you're
generating Python expression and so on
and so forth so
can I say this is clear this is one
example I mean notebooks are amazing to
do visualization so you are working here
just with Python and then at some point
is a let me let me quickly see this data
and then you're using word from language
to do that that is one use case there
are plenty of them I hope people will
figure out I think this is a library
that allows you to be very creative and
I can imagine all kind of acts going on
with this library but another thing that
you can do is and you will sure to do it
you have a you have a Python code right
and you and you have a functionality
that is missing in pattern you want to
use Wolfram language for that and you
can and you can have a code that is
creating a lot of Wolfram language
expressions then you start up a kernel
pool and you start evaluating all those
all those expression in parallel either
on your local machine or on the Wolfram
cloud you get back the result and you
have and you aggregate them and you want
in in Python so that that allows
basically to move from Python to Wolfram
language go back to widen and continue
which is the other direction of external
evaluate external evaluate you are using
word from language you start using
Python with external evaluate and then
you continue
language so this is the other direction
if a got a value yes this is gonna be in
this case it's going to be system a you
need to do global dot a then you do a
equal to 13 and from the context any
system and so basically just need to
refer it explicitly to to the right
context it's a variable if a is a
variable in Python then of course yes
just the value is so if you do a equals
to sure but that is that there is a yeah
but there is a difference that is the
difference this is a Python variable
okay and the other one it's a symbolic
key that is a variable that reference to
the kernel so they are not the same
right so this factory allows you to
identify what is war from language I
really in the starts with this WL in
your code is the war from language stuff
everything else is not but in any case I
mean this advance is evaluating
expression is something is something
neat is something that you know is very
powerful also something there is an
advanced use let's let's start with its
you know just regular data structure
because another use case is that you
have a library that is producing data
right you are doing some kind of
analysis in Python and you know you
don't need symbols for that you only
need data structures you only need lists
dictionaries numbers reals stuff like
that so you have a you have a set of
data is coming from a database is coming
from an API and instead of using JSON to
be mitigated you can directly use wxf
now or or or or the input form it gets
you the advantage of supporting a lot
more data types than what
J'son can do so the built in type that
we are supporting are all the obvious so
list is supported set is supported set
is set is the set ease is a set of
element that got no limitation as you
can see in set I got one two two four
and duplications get the leader this is
happening in pider
set ISA is a data structure that can no
duplicates then there is the list and
since we don't have these data
structures we are always those are all
equivalent for us they are all list the
other data structures that we do have is
the dictionary that is transformed into
an association
by default what we have done is that
everything that imp idle got an eater
method in the object it's transformed
and converted automatically into a
Wolfram language it is because we don't
have as well generators so particularly
the obvious thing to do when you get a
generator is to transform it into a list
so if you can evaluate this guy these
will be converted into a list and you
will see also the generator is a
generator function that does yelled I
know many people are familiar with
Python but this is a core part of the
language and it n is automatically
converted into a list in Python to
dictionary are not guaranteeing in any
case the order so if you need to
while associations are always ordered so
if you need other structures that that
that guarantees the order there is order
addict in built-in Python and we are
supporting this as well if um okay yes
below and yeah then we have data types
like strings as our same string is
converted into a regular string while by
while binary while bytes is converted
into bi into binary we also have support
from for all kinds of number like the
decimal and is converted using fixed
position complex are also converted
infinity indeterminate are also
converted to the right symbol in
Mathematica directly fractions are also
supported those are all built-in modules
in Python they are transformed to
rational
and we got support for date as well so
as you can see like all those data types
you cannot really compare them easily
with JSON you need to invent your way to
serialize those type because in JSON
they're not supported
you only have floating-point number
integrals true/false none and strings
that's it there is no support for for
dates and you need to always parse the
string so on the other hand with this
with this library we are providing a one
to one conversion for a lot of native
data types so tiny is converted to Dame
object the day time object and also the
data object are automatically converted
time Delta are converted using
quantities which make sense for us as
well because in Python you can
summertime Delta with a date and you get
out another date
Wolfram language you can sum a date
object with a quantity and get out
another date and we're also supporting
they do object with timestamps sorry
time aware information and this is how
you can create your own normalization so
let's say that you have a class that
needs to produce some arbitrary code
like a data object like whatever it is
like an association with several
information inside you can easily do
that by importing our word firm language
serializable you inherit from this guy
and then you define this method and this
method needs to return one of the
primitive that I just showed you and
this will recursively normalize your
class and do the regression
appropriately so this you see that this
class was returning my world from lang
function with some argument that I was
sending into in it and so now my Python
class becomes my Wolfram language
function when serialized we are also
supporting one third party data type
that is numpy arrays and they are
efficiently transformed into numerically
by just taking the C representation that
numpy is using and moving it into the
the the serialization this is a this can
be done only with wxf and i mean just a
quick quick tour of basically the
performance of room and that we managed
to do between eleven point two and
twelve by switching to WX f WX f what is
double X F very quickly because we don't
have much time but double X F is a
binary representation of expressions
it's a noble format that is documented
you can see the documentation and the
nice thing about it is that it can be
implemented as serialize and deserialize
in almost every language we started by
doing Python which means that from
Mathematica you can serialize to double
X F and read it back from Python or from
Python you can use you can basically use
this binary format that is open and
augmented to produce arbitrary
expression before we were just using a
naive implementation of the
serialization was just using input form
and I would get terrible performance and
now with double itself you can see that
there is a consistent speed up
and yeah as I was saying that the the
main entry point will allow you in in
one case to just say target format wxf
and these got now back by the Ray oops
and binary can be interpreted by doing
import wide array of this guy double
yourself and as will give it back the
expression of course you can dump it to
a file there is a syntax to do that if
you just send here a string then it's
been written on a file or otherwise you
can use a context manager to open a file
and export to a file like object in
Python that works with a files string
i/o bytes a or all file like objects in
Python I just need to provide a bright
method and any will work with them and
this realization also work by a single
and three point so you take a dump you
do binary digitalize and you get back
the very same expressions and there is a
method to customize what to do when
reading the wxf done so it did this is
all documented so this is just a quick
overview I think like if you are
interested you can go and read the
documentation is like very easy tool and
I think we did our best to write in in a
way that it's easy and comprehensible to
be able so I will just ask now okay so
let's move on to the next step stone so
far were only representing expressions
so it was maybe a bit confusing because
we represent the expression in Python
and when the expression was that and
come arrive in the kernel we know what
to do with it and evaluate it but all
all the examples that now I'm going to
show you you have to imagine that we
we are in a Python interpreter and we
stay inside in the Python interpreter
all the time so if you see an evaluation
it will happens without the kernel that
is used to do the presentation sort of
so it we are going to show the the use
case of a pure Python program sort of so
I'm going to demo you how the library
managed to issue a issue to evaluate
expression on the local kernel
eventually also evaluate main expression
in parallel and and then move on to
interaction with the whorfin cloud that
we have a lot of baller code plate that
we have implemented and and see how we
can call API in evaluate in cloud so
let's start so the main class to
interact with the warm kernel is a is
the warframe language session and also
as we as we saw there is one very
convenient way to represent expression
which is the factory WL so I imported on
board I import both of them then
obviously if I connect and interact with
the kernel I need to specify the path so
this is typically the path to a kernel
if you have a Mac and so I specify it
and then I define I initialize my my
session okay so for a moment there is
not much that happened because as you
can imagine if you interact with the
kernel you need a process and and so you
need to start it manage it eventually
terminate it so the good point is that
you don't have to actually initialize
since if the session is not initialized
when you first evaluate we do it for you
and okay so that's why it took maybe one
second for two very distinct which if I
do it again it's immediate so here
this this this code was totally in
Python so I was in Python I send a
string to I mean I define a string
reverse function that Python does not
really know what it is I applied to a
string which is a Python string and I
get back a Python string that luckily
the kernel can also say right so that's
why I also get warfarin screen war from
string in the output and if you are in
Python it would be a Python string and
now I can also start to see how it this
can be very useful because with this
kind of stuff in class and you can see
the Wolfram language as a huge library
of functions that you can call from
Python very efficiently and so here for
example I want to use Wolfram Alpha
which has probably no equivalent and I
don't know see what's the population of
Illinois's for example so evaluated it's
a bit longer because we're from alpha is
I am I connected we'll see we figure out
okay and so we're from alpha is
returning me a quantity and I happen to
know what to do with it and so that's
why it is serialized nicely I think with
the example I'm going to show just after
that that you can actually keeps on
working on the expression from the
Python side even if you don't really
know what it is but I just I showed this
example and maybe I you tell me if it's
that's the fame going to show thank you
for supporting everything so for this
presentation we start in the Wolfram
language in Mathematica we go into
Python yes but this is artificial
exactly and then from Python we go to
another kernel and get back the result
and then eventually goes out to Python
into this presentation that book so you
have a surrounding or foreign language
layer that it is artificial the inner
one yes so you sometimes it can be very
cumbersome to write expressions using WL
that's something because if you think
about for example a functions and when
you have slots in them etc and so we we
implemented the the evaluation using
pure string so you can type input input
form and it will just work okay so that
that's very convenient from time to time
you can I mean as as Ricardo showed you
you can mix and match native Python type
with symbols so you can apply for
example min max on to Python array yes
we inferred that probably there is no
use case to evaluate the pure string in
the kernel so
no because if you so the question is can
you more less civilize input form from
Python and the answer is no we can't I
mean we decided not to go in this
direction it's probably complicated so
I'm going to be to explain Manas which
what you asked I think so let's say I
want to compute the AIDS of the mum law
so this as we saw it's it's a quantity
so in Python usually if you get by the
quantity you don't really know what to
do with it I mean you could you could
extract the value maybe but again but
now I say okay I get back the quantity
and actually I should show it so it's in
feet but let's say I'm using the metric
system so I'd like thank you I'd like to
to the unit convert on it first so that
I get meters as you can see I can pass
the variable this is a Python variables
and I pass it into my my expressions and
and convert it but now I'm not done
because I say I'd like to have a value a
numeric value because it bite on you
don't really care what the quantity is
and so I apply quantity magnitude on top
of my last result and so I get back this
time a real number and this this example
is a bit artificial because I could have
of obviously call quantity magnitude of
unit convert of the result for more
formal fun but imagine you have
something you can have some intermediate
intermediary steps where it's pure
Python for example so you can check for
whatever you want
I think it's the next slide maybe the
next next slide but yes so it's as I
told you that you start a process and
the hood so the session is persistent
yes
yes no I mean it's a more or less but WL
is a factory so when you do WL dot
something it produces a an object and
this this eight is this kind of objects
the very well function oh it's not so
realizable so yeah yes so you can do
ours I think and it's the second hogs so
I think it's this no it's do yeah you
can but you mean for example yeah maybe
you can implement it it's no purchase
project so we accept your contributions
just fight a PR and ah interesting
it's yeah yes definitely yes so we yeah
if you we encourage so if you have
contributions of course that's the best
but you can also have some ideas that
you want implemented and we can
no it's on github actress yeah in the
library the library was tested on eleven
point three you have better performances
with twelve but problem so it works for
twelve okay so but session persistency
actually I was right it was the next
line okay so I define a function so it's
written nothing in Python so I get none
and as you may know when you define
variables as a session by default they
are in the global context and actually I
can do no that's that was stupid because
this is not this session it's the other
one the nested one okay and so if I want
to call it I can use the again the
constructor and and apply my function to
write an integer and yes if you forget
about the global the global the global
context then nothing happens because
system F is not defined this WL dot F
defined system F which is not defined
okay that can be a bit confusing if you
because we hide the context for global
in system so you can also define pure
function in Python so in this case I'd
like to say I have this select prime Q
that I'm going to use a lot for example
and so I want I want to store it in a
variable as a callable object so you can
say session then function have a pure
function in it or not a proportion to
the function and this does nothing but
then you can apply it on the list and it
will evaluate as if you did select prime
Q something and you can you can imagine
anything here even
something like I don't know a pure a
pure function that's abstract this know
exactly I'm making use of the operator
forms yes so it's equivalent to this I
know what you mean by functor okay so in
Python it's called call a ball I think
but we talked about the same thing and
so I can apply my prime Q again so in
this case I applied prime prime Q on an
inter tour so I mix pure Python things
that we can't really represent as a
function with the function a quick
example of parallel valuation and which
under the hood makes use of what we call
a pool of kernel so in this case I have
this this expression which integrates a
function on the surface of this type of
volumes okay so it's just a way to have
a computation that takes around 5
seconds as you can see so I first I
define my entire expressions with which
is long to evaluate so I I'm not going
to use that very well that's something
because it's it's going to be impossible
to read so instead I copy paste it in a
string and then I have a bit of code to
to see how long it will take so I have I
start the contour and then I parallel
evaluate I have to specify the path of
the kernel that that is going to be I
mean path to the executable and then I
evaluate for for time this this
expression which has some randomness in
it and I let's see how what the result
was
yeah nice okay so let's use the former
example but what I want you to show is
that I have full time for expression
that takes five five seconds to evaluate
and it evaluate in the end and yesterday
but still in seven seconds which is more
or less two seconds to start the
colonel's for them and then five seconds
each on each channel so I in this case I
had four candles that managed to start
in time and and consume the expression
to value and for some reason I external
evaluate I think I know okay so I know
if you use parallel evaluate it will
start a pool to the evaluation and
contaminate it if you if you if you want
to use a kernel pool as a counter
session that the one that I was using
before which you need to start and stop
you need to use the underlying class
that I'm not going to show in this
example but it's documented we haven't
we haven't show you the documentation
but there is a very big documentation
where everything is explained with first
the the basic use cases and then if you
want to go deeper we have advanced
example so I invited you to check for
documentation
so paralyzed in Python yeah that's my
next slide I think no so just first
before I go to the last part which is
really advanced oh I was not sure I had
time to do it when you start a session
you need to terminate it all the time
why is that you know that in the warm
language I some licensing restrictions
for example so if you have more than n
corners running you cannot start a new
one so you need it's like your database
connections like a file like anything
new when you open it you need to close
it so let's close the session but
sometimes I mean depends what you want
to do but can be very useful to to delay
to delegate this the session management
to the Python interpreter so in this
case you can use the with structure so
it's like open if you're familiar to it
with it so you do with what some
language session as a session yeah and
then you can use it and terminate it can
I write this weird bug I don't know what
it was but okay this is very useful when
because if you if you have some code
that raise exceptions for example and
you don't catch them you end up not
terminating your session and your code
is going to run four times maybe six
eight and after the ninth attempt it's
going to to print a failure because it
cannot start a new kernel because you
have already eight kernels often can was
running when possible exactly except if
you want it to be stored in a class and
use because also you have to know that
of course there is a cost to start
kernel it's more least one second so in
order to mitigate it you start the
session and store it somewhere and use
it obviously
I thought about adding something I have
one for me I mean it's not really
it's a one-liner in shell so you can you
can do you can check for the processes
check for warfarin kernels and then
check for a specific function that I
call to start the kernel that is not
even in in system so it's fairly with
with really few greps you can kill all
the kernels that are it's just that for
example on Windows it's probably a
different way of doing it but I thought
about doing it so there was a question
maybe I'm okay so before I move on to
the more advanced topic of concurrent
processes and encouraged ins and how to
evaluate in parallel from Python I I
will quickly show you maybe the the
cloud how you interact with the cloud so
you have similarly to local kernel you
have a Wolfram cloud section this one
doesn't have to be terminated because
does not restore anything critical by
default we are targeting the warm public
cloud but you can specify your own
server if you have one like a private
private cloud for example you can call
an API so for the moment I'm going to do
I'm not authenticated but I'm going to
so I'm going to call a public API of my
own and this one is printing a range and
an output format as a as a JSON string
so how you define an API you can define
API with the tupple so you specify the
username which is the first part of the
URL here and then you specify the
relative path to your home directory so
let's do that and then you simply do
cloud core my API that I have defined
and of
course and AP I need some input I mean
not all the time but this one expect
I've eyeballs and and so I evaluate
using five and so since a lot of things
can happen in the when you call the
cloud in this case the result is not
directly the the the evaluations so you
can check whether or not there was a
success it was successful or not in this
case it was okay good and so you get
back the result now that you are used to
this mix and mash of kernels and Python
stuff you can infer that this this was a
byte a byte string so it bites in Python
tree and so I can directly import it as
a cheese in a string and a byte array
and and get back the result okay so this
was with the kernel but now let's say I
I want to stay in Python so I just
import JSON and do the same import my
choosing result and I would get back an
array Python array okay so what if I
want to authenticate in three minutes so
to authenticate with the cloud you need
you need to generate a pair of secured
key to attend to get yourself so that
you you you don't have to use your
warframe ID and password and and I have
I have one so it's this one so it's too
long chain of base64 encoded string okay
so I'm going to use this pair consumer
key and consumer secret they represent
more or less my login and password so so
I import the classes that represent this
this way of authenticating I create a
session using my my two informations and
this time I I start a class session
using authentication equal and this
secure authentication key and now I can
check that I am authorized okay and with
this
I can no do plot evaluation because my
account I have an account under publicly
under the PV cloud so I can evaluate
expression in the cloud
so it's no more black box when something
goes wrong and exactly and you have the
full stack all the variables it's
external evaluate features yes
okay so contrary to local kernel this is
one shot evaluation so if I define X and
evaluate it it does not exist anymore to
probably are familiar with it you can
define function as well targeting the
cloud and so now maybe to finish such a
seconds concurrent features and a thank
you probably not the the simplest path
but so if you want to start evaluation
in parallel you can use we have two
classes because in pattern you have two
ways to do that either using concurrent
feature which is a thread based is or
using a Sankyo which was introduced in
3.5 or 4 which is based on coroutines
so you have a loop with event and when
an events occurred but i'm not going to
explain i mean it's it's it's even based
and so if you if you start a war from
language future session this one is
returning future objects which means
that you you do when you evaluate
something here instead of having the
result immediately as you can see i'm
doing a post to so it's going to sleep
for two seconds and anywhere it's
something you get back immediately
something an object that you can use to
say is the result already available or
not and and so you can do other stuff
and at some point when you actually need
the result you can you can call on your
future object result with the timeout
and and so and so as you can see i start
the session i start a session i evaluate
something that is slow the evaluation
took 1 milliseconds and I get back my
future object and after 2 seconds my
future object is a variable and with the
result that I'm expecting and you can do
stuff similar with a Sankyo okay so
without
syntax coloring is even harder to follow
but syntax EO is very useful when you
have well ye operation that takes fair
amount of time you can parallel evaluate
in in parallel in background tasks wait
for some result gather the results and
so in this example the main the main
part is here so I do ensure future which
means evaluate this core routine in
parallel and returns me something that I
can then await and I start another one
yeah and and those are actually delayed
with a thank you so imagine you have
database something that's happening file
operation that takes some time that
chooses a thank you so in this example
it's faked so I'm using sleep only and
then I evaluate and if you do that again
you can see that i very two tasks but it
takes two seconds so it evaluate in
parallel as expected
sure that's so this is the github
repository we just added everything
yesterday you have all the source code
available you have one branch amazing
yours it's master your power user so you
have documentation that for a moment
it's storing a temporary locations but
it's pretty much it's well advanced
it it's using the thumb dad Python way
of documenting things you have how to
install it then you have an
introductions introductions to to all
more less all that we discussed today
with example etc etc so and then you
have also so as you can see you have a
lot of topics covered on the side this
is only on this page and then you have
also an advanced part where you have the
Sankyo examples for example with syntax
grown you can copy paste the code in
first immediately and yeah that's it
thank you
[Applause]